most screenwriters understand that they
should know the ending of their story
before they start writing can you
explain how the same logic applies to
understanding the business yeah
um that's something I
had a challenge sort of defining for a
while myself and then I realized it's
actually a lot simpler than I thought
about it it's just it's it's us it's
it's we call ourselves end users we are
people who actually pay for content
so if you have a Netflix subscription
you're an end user if you pay for
tickets to a movie you're an end user we
are the actual audience that's paying
money and funding the whole
entertainment business
so looking at us what do audiences like
how are we split into groups what genres
pop with certain demographics
that is what Studios care about that's
what networks care about that is what
any sort of consumer direct to Consumer
facing company will care about so it's
sort of the same idea they are using
that information to sort of delineate
what content should we go for what
content should we avoid
so if you look at different television
channels they are all targeted to very
sort of specific audience categories
they have similar genres they have very
similar themes
um and
they tend to not they tend to speak to
very different groups and they don't
have a whole lot of overlap
I think this is probably the most
visible with cable news where you see
very polarized views of the world
speaking to very specific audiences and
all they care about is speaking to that
one Target and nobody else if a company
is releasing the Twilight films they're
doing the same thing they really want to
Keep Their audience happy so that they
can make the second and the third film
if they're doing the Fast and Furious
franchise they really want to keep that
audience happy so they can keep sort of
churning out one title to the next so
very long-winded way of answering this
but it's basically you're correct if
you're going to write a script you have
to know how it ends because you
structure everything leading up to it
when we're doing distribution deals when
I'm sort of getting films financed or
getting television shows off the ground
we are thinking the exact same way but
are sort of how are we going to make
this work we're looking at an audience
we're looking at a company that speaks
to that audience because most of what I
do Works in what we call like the B2B or
business to business end of things I'm
doing deals directly with the studios or
I'm doing deals directly with um other
entities that are direct to Consumer so
television channels or VOD platforms Etc
they care about their audience they want
content that's going to Keep Their
audience happy and engaged and watching
I need to give them content that's going
to ensure that that takes place so I'm
absolutely using the metrics the data
the information I can gather or that
they can share with me about who Their
audience is what they like how they like
content to feel how they like it to be
structured how they like it to flow and
then I work backwards and those are the
kinds of films we look for those are the
kinds of screenplays we try to find we
try to find writers who can sort of
deliver in that world and that's sort of
what keeps that supply chain going
what else do writers need to know about
the traditional script to screen mode of
thinking
I would reverse it it's
I I think when you're starting out it's
it's the whatever is going to get a
couple scripts like under your belt so
to speak like follow it but um once you
sort of get a much better command of
your craft you have the confidence that
you can write feature-length scripts
with relative ease it's not easy at all
but I mean the fact that you know you
can do it once you've sort of reached
that point you need to sort of stop
thinking about
the script to screen approach and start
thinking about what do screens need and
then write that because that's how our
industry really operates it's it's if
you look at the Cannes Film Festival or
the Berlin Film Festival
a lot of people have a mindset that the
film gets made and then you take it to
the festival and then sort of present it
to the world with the hope of getting
distribution and it's like no the
distribution was set up before the film
was even shot that's a big marketing
stunt that's just getting it out there
and showing people like look how great
this movie is we want Awards Etc maybe
very small Independent films go to the
markets and haven't yet secured
distribution but the big ones they're
already taken and they're locked and you
sort of have to think about
screenwriting the same way you need to
approach it as what do these television
channels need what do these outlets need
what are the core genres that make that
work uh I've I
wrote about that years and years ago in
in my first book and it was those have
not changed like
Christmas movies they make hundreds
every single year it's like Christmas is
coming this year and I guarantee you
it's going to come next year too and
there's going to be a big content need
and a lot of networks and a lot of TV
channels all over the world
um really Bank on that action films with
aging male Heroes you can shoot them
very economically and you can get all
kinds of known Talent
um who can be in those films you can
shoot them for a day or two and you have
this big celebrity you have on the
poster but those same scripts they work
at very low budget levels but they also
work at much bigger budget levels the
genre is what's important I wouldn't do
a horror film but you could do a
Creature Feature something with some
kind of a tangible
visual thing and not just sort of the
standard issue sort of slasher film and
then I'm I'm personally a big fan of
like
tween girl romance films those do
extraordinarily well both as movies and
as well as TV series there's a lot of
latitude in those genres you can work in
so those are the things that I think
writers need to think about is these are
the genres that are going to sell I call
them Gold Mine genres that's not like an
industry term but it's uh those are the
genres that sell so if you're writing in
those buckets
uh you're writing what the industry
depends on through good times bad times
inflation non-inflation periods and uh
that's what the industry builds itself
on
forgive me why not horror horror is just
horror and comedy are just really really
really hard to pull off I I call these
latitudes of failure which again is not
like an industry term it's just
something I made up but it's um
it's like
if you're gonna write something or shoot
something if you're going to make a
movie on spec whatever it is there are
certain genres that like you gotta nail
it or it's just a dud and a comedy or a
horror film if you have like if it's 99
on point but there's like one or two
things in it that aren't ideal
uh it just like loses interest or it
loses Market placement opportunities
whereas if you have a family movie
that's very family safe if you have a
Christmas Romance movie with a dog in it
or like
a tween girl and a horse movie any of
these that like aren't
perfectly executed or there's like maybe
not the best coverage of a scene
um they still get bought and they still
get picked up and you can shoot them on
very low budgets and even if they don't
come out perfectly like there's an
audience for it because television
networks and VOD platforms around the
world love that stuff their Advertiser
safe they're they're very family
co-viewing friendly uh I mean Christmas
movies are a good example I don't think
many people actually watch them but
they're just like background fill and
people like to have them on and so
there's not a whole lot of dedication to
the viewership of them outside of a
select group of people so it's um but
networks love them because they really
turn in the ratings so that's the kind
of thinking you have to have is if
you're going for a genre like comedy or
horror I'm not saying don't do it I'm
saying like
work on it but maybe don't have it be
your out of the gate project that you're
trying to sort of get an agent with
there's always outliers of course
there's always examples people can cite
of like well this person did it and that
person did it and it's like yeah they
did but the vast majority of people
that's not going to be the path they
follow